est-ce que vous avez déjà fait les
rencontres dans un avion que d'art moi
j'adore trois fois trois fois c'est à
dire trois fois l'amour dans la zone a
duré qu'une inconnue que je ne
connaissais pas que je monte dans
l'avion d'arrêt je vous jure n'en a
arrêté une fois enfants en venant de los
angeles n'était pas pour le travail
c'est parti à tahiti j'ai fait une
escale à san francisco san francisco
paris une autre fois en venant du paris
dakar dakar et une autre fois on veut
nantes viennent trois fois ils
déjeunaient ses parents et ses seins
dérapages dans la vie mais viennent ça
n'a pas duré longtemps mais vous je
t'emmerde mais je prédis de vol c'est
des circonstances qui font ça bah quoi
non parce que viennent ces cours oui bah
quelle séparation c'est assez classique
mais par exemple pour le comme le seul
chef à san francisco paris si une
américaine qui monte à côté de moi on
était juste pas moi qui paye le billet
dont j'étais en première
voilà un 747 est à côté de moi et on
n'avait pas envie de dormir donc on
était au bar dans la bosse du 747 ont bu
des verres comme ça et un moment elles
rythment le film s dans votre slip ll
discuter avec le barman du bar du 747
comme ça un moment j'étais la pub but
j'étais un peu jaloux donc comment ça me
saoule et je vais genre de tournoi va
perdre à l'autre deux heures on avait
sympathisé et du coup jour par ma place
tout le monde dormait les gens avec des
masses sur les trucs que l'avion était
en plein sommeil mais et à un moment
elle voit je suis parti elle revient me
voir me semble pourquoi tu es parti je
lui dis je suis désolé je suis un peu
jaloux
emelyne a aucune raison et à ce
moment-là a annoncé m'embrasser ouais
c'était oui ce faire le bar mal apprécié
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
fantasment ceux de faire l'amour une
fois avec un inconnu
mais jean michel maire c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup sénégal je ne saurai jamais son
prénom n'a pas dit un mot
non mais vous benhaim ah bah non chez un
traiteur qu'acteur je commande
iam est toujours bonne derrière comme en
a pas de merguez inédit on se regarde
pas du tout la même ambiance
je joue c'est un boulet tout comme un
prélat et là je vous dis je gêne et riza
kouli la foule est vieilli dans la tête
pour saha c'est dingue quand même en si
peu de temps la mutuelle vous quoi dans
l'avion moi je dors laissez moi vous
êtes pas du tout sophie non mais c'est
fou la réserve comme ça il n'a connu
moi j'ai déjà fait des choses dans
l'avion mais avec la personne avec qui
j'étais monté dans l'avion pas avec un
inconnu
est-ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
déjà fait quelque chose avec un inconnu
dit la vérité avec i'm inconnu attendez
attendez à l'accord raconter d'histoires
oui c'est pas vrai si que tu connaissais
pas du tout à fait inconnu quoi par
définition 3 avec toi tu connais place
alors oui quelqu'un tu me connais pas et
des commandements et tu connais un tout
petit peu mieux après on vous souhaitez
quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune
j'étais bien j'étais dévergondée après
non j'ai passé quinze ans avec le père
de mes enfants donc après angers dire
elle s'était passé comment c'était
qu'ils y allaient ça devait être alors
celui dont je me souviens je me souviens
de celui-ci
c'était dans un bar c'était dans un café
en fait j'ai pas une américaine qui
était en train de regarder pad
américaine mais ses 46 pas si beau mais
très jeune vraiment très jeune et en
fait je sais pas avec un petit catogan
un peu lookée petite barbe etc
j'ai trouvé assez mignon et j'ai bon
ouais je fais du bien par là et c'était
très sympa non c'est vrai
zerrouki stabilité parce qu'il est
célibataire devra bien sûr veut on a le
droit valade être attentionné comme ça à
décomplexer baida suivent généralement
si je regardais truc là et je me disais
mais moi je sais ce qui me trouve
[Rires]
plus la loire parce qu'elle dit et tu as
suivi et moi les gens voient pas moi
j'ai sophie qui est là et à la voile à
savoir qui est magnifique et jouer les
sa jambe depuis tout à l'heure des
maisons jeu honnête je dis moi je tiens
pu évidemment qu'il a suivi nos guerres
dans le bar forcément c'est quoi ça
qu'est ce qu'on aime c'est le bar c'est
un bar terrasse et une émission bt en
appétit j'adore vous kelly est ce que
vous avez déjà dans l'avion on a déjà
benhaim et vous sur l aller non mais
franchement j'ai jamais fait l'amour
dans un avion dans un bus h et passera
fantômes non une autre voiture dans un
tunnel quand tu sortes ta fille
quelqu'un y en a partout tunnel sous la
manche
enfin quoi dès qu'il ya des moyens de
transport sais pas danser comme
tromperie dans tout l'imaginaire dans la
littérature en concert tromper quelqu'un
qu'on va partir mais on est en mouvement
dans un avion au dessus alors agressé
deux ford amour et rentrer chez toi et à
ta femme je ne t'ai pas trompés parce
qu'on était dans le thalys ou alors
est-ce des arrivées mais tu te fais
choper carte afin qu'un poil mais chut
on est dans le travail n'est pas cette
personne mais s'est dit dans la
littérature nous met un coup de canif et
ratures je me comprends